if you looked at mental health
statistics of practitioners these days
particularly in the United States this
is not what we kind of signed up for
because most of what comes in our door
about 80 percent in Primary Care are
these chronic diseases for which we have
very little to offer patients and kind
of traditional medical model but instead
of giving fully informed consent the
system is set up to kind of reward bad
behavior the most profitable doctor
visit in North America is a blood
pressure check easiest you know if you
fit it in a few minutes you get to bill
for it and it's the most common Primary
Care visit and for a condition that need
not happen at all high blood pressure
lifestyle disease but that entire sector
of the field would be gone both big
Pharma and big medicine I mean no one
benefits from people eating healthier
name one industry that would benefit
from people eating healthier and you say
well what about the health insurance
industry don't they benefit from people
because they have to pay for it all no
they get a slice of the pie and the
bigger the pie the bigger the slice the
system is just set up to reward these
behaviors and make people sick